Alon Ozer, thank you for being
on 20 Minute Leaders. How are you?
I’m good. I’m wonderful.
Thank you very much.
You’re calling from
Miami, Florida, right?
Yes, yes. Correct.
And while things may not be
looking up now, by the time
this is aired,
it will go better, right?
Yes, a hundred percent.
A hundred percent.
Alon, right before this talk,
we discovered that I have no idea
what are the responsibilities
of running a family office
and with managing
wealth of families.
So, I’m very excited for this chat
and to learn as much
as I can over these 20 minutes.
Yes, I'll be happy
to tell you what we do.
Alon, what is a family office?
Let’s start from the basics
because it sounds
like I just don’t know.
No, you were pretty close.
A family office is a family
that service families
that accumulated wealth.
It's sometimes the first
generation, sometimes the second,
it could be the third,
and even the fourth generation
that holds that wealth.
What we do is not only
managing the wealth,
we also service them
in other capacities.
as advisers,
as wealth planners,
helping them with the exits,
helping them with estate taxes,
and also educating
the next generation
about the wealth
that they accumulated.
And wealth comes
with a lot of responsibility.
So, hold on, you just intro  --
it’s like opened Pandora’s box
because you’re basically saying
like you do everything for
the family, because it sounds like
there’s so many moving parts
besides educating
the new generation,
all of a sudden, you have this --
you have like an 18-year old
who’s now venturing into the world
and his or her family has wealth,
and they want to be
educated about that.
You’re saying you’re also helping
them understand the taxes
behind their estates and --
What you mentioned before,
which was fascinating,
was that you don’t necessarily
just look for new opportunities
to advance the wealth,
but you’re al --
you’re mainly looking
to preserve the wealth
and how to do
that responsibly, right?
Right. Of course, you have
different types of families
and different types of --
So if the son’s still at a young
age, still wants to accumulate
more wealth.
So, you might have different
objectives and different people.
But in general, these people have
accumulated a lot of wealth.
At some point, what you want to do
is take the majority of that wealth
and move it, and manage it in a way
that you preserve your capital.
You grow it by, let’s say, 5%
plus inflation
or something like that.
But the most important thing
is you want to manage your risk.
You want to stay in the game.
You want to don’t have --
You don’t want to have
drawdowns of 20%, 30% where this
could actually change
your life, your standard of living.
This is something
you don’t want to happen.
At this point, you also want
to focus more about philanthropy.
A lot of them do philanthropy
early on, but at some point,
you get to that stage where you can
really make a difference.
And they all want to do that.
Okay. And how do you even get to be
and to earn a family office?
So, what path did you take in life
to get to the point
where you’re reaching this --
where you’re doing this
and you’re excited by this work?
It’s kind of boring.
I always did the same thing.
[laughs]
It’s not --
I mean, I finished
my military service.
I joined the Ministry of Defense
[unclear].
And then, I started
just working as a trader.
That was a very long time ago.
And you chose to go into
family offices instead of
going into investment banking,
instead of going to Wall Street.
I mean, you had a bunch
of different options, right?
Right. So, prior to this position,
I managed an endowment.
An endowment is like the --
you know, Funds [unclear],
Yale [unclear], Harvard...
All these --
There are a lot of stories
about these types of funds.
So, I managed the fund
like that for nine years.
And at some point,
when I decided to move forward --
I didn’t want to go back
to the old Wall Street,
I call it, where --
some of it, conflict of interests.
It’s all about the sales.
It’s all about the --
I wanted to be able to do
the work that I love,
which is mostly the research.
And I always tell people,
90% of the work is the research;
10% is the actual investments.
It takes time to get to that point
where you can pull the trigger.
Yeah, you know,
I’m imagining you sitting
in the office with the fam --
like in the family office
managing the wealth.
And all day, you’re trading.
All day, you’re signing checks
and you’re making transactions.
I guess that’s not the case.
No, not at all. Not at all.
We do a lot of work.
We speak to
a lot of people
in terms of
the research that we do --
Yeah.
-- with smart people in the world.
It’s either real estate,
it’s private equity,
venture, private debts.
You name it.
We want to really drill down into
these types of investments
to understand where
the market is going,
what should we be doing,
where are the opportunities,
and where are the risks,
which is the most important thing.
Right. And so, then I guess --
do you work with the family
on understanding what type of
risk portfolio you want to have?
Is it high risk, low risk?
What type of investments
you’re more comfortable with?
And then, once you decide together,
you move on to looking
at that vertical and narrowing down
on the actual investments?
Yes, correct.
Each person, each family
have their own risk tolerance,
have their own objectives,
have their own desires
in terms of,
again, philanthropy or education
of the next generation.
So, it's a little bit different.
But the truth is that,
first of all, we have
our investment methodology,
which is very strict,
very process-driven,
very research-driven.
And when you get to that point
of actually pulling the trigger
on some investments,
there are not too many
opportunities, right?
A lot of the stuff that you see,
and you hear about, it’s okay.
It’s not great because we invest
in a more institutional way.
We are very strict with the type
of investments
that we’re going to do.
Institutional is
synonymous to low-risk?
No, not necessarily.
I don’t mind taking risks
as long as I’m getting
compensated for it.
A lot of times you’re going to see
deals that have the high risk,
but the compensation
is not necessarily there.
So, that’s something
that we’re not going to take.
In terms of institutions
I talk about --
I mean, the management of the --
for example, investment fund,
their ability of back office,
the diligence, the research.
We want to invest with people
that have done it a lot of times.
And the reality is
that if you look
at private equity venture,
the dispersion in returns
between the top tier --
Yeah.
-- and the second one
is so big that I don’t think
you have the choice
as a wealth manager
to be with the second tier.
You want to stick to the top ones.
Now, not necessarily
you’re going to have the access --
- Not necessarily --
- Right.
-- you’re going to
have the ability to --
But that’s what we work for.
We use our experience,
our relationships, our firepower
to get into these investments.
So, when a family chooses the
right people to run their wealth,
I guess --
And one thing that I was --
One thing I was thinking,
of course, was that
your credibility
and your experience.
But it sounds like your network
and your ability to get into
the right investments,
that’s just a critical piece,
just like in venture capital,
were as good as
the deal flow we’re getting.
And if don’t have access
to the best deals,
then it doesn’t matter how good
we are at looking at --
at doing due diligence,
we’re not getting access
to the best investments.
Yes.
But the first thing that you said
is the more important thing.
First of all,
it’s your credibility --
Of course.
-- [inaudible] they give you
to manage their wealth.
You become part of their family.
They have to be able to trust you.
- They'd be able to --
- I want to ask about that, yeah.
-- do what they want.
So that's the first step.
Second, it’s the access.
But also, it’s the way that you --
it’s everything together.
It’s the process.
It’s the risk management.
It’s not just the best deals.
You can have the access
to a lot of deals.
If you don’t want --
know how to put them together,
you might have overlaps in different
areas in the portfolio.
And when September 2020 comes,
everything goes down together.
Yeah.
And that doesn’t work.
But getting access
to the best deals is definitely --
it's extremely important.
It’s not easy,
but it’s very important.
And how do you build
that trust with the family?
Because it sounds like different
from an investment banker,
or Wall Street,
or a venture capital,
you’re dealing with souls.
You’re dealing with people
who are putting their trust in you,
their hard-earned money with you.
How do you build that trust?
Is it over time?
Do you apply to it
like a job application?
How does that work?
Yeah, it takes time.
First of all, this business
is all word-of- mouth.
You get references from friends,
clients, people that think
that you’re doing a good job.
Or they think
that you’re a good person,
and that’s why they refer
other people to you.
Then it’s a matter of time.
We really have to earn
the trust and it’s not something
that they do widely.
There are a lot other things
that people are not aware
of that are going on
in this market; for example,
the whole conflict of interest
in this business,
which is the worst thing.
Every time I’m about
to ask you a question,
you bring it up before me.
It’s incredible.
Yes, conflict of interest
in managing family wealth.
Is it a big thing?
Is it hard?
Is it --?
Like how do you even avoid that?
Or how do you keep checks
and balances on that?
You have to keep checks
and balances, absolutely.
And we have our own
compliance officer that always
goes and makes sure
that everybody is in compliance.
But the reality is that,
look, in every --
and I’m not bashing here
anybody or --
I’m just saying in --
the model of Wall Street
and the way that all
the big guys work --
the Goldmans, the Merrills, the --
is that when they put you
in an investment --
private equity, private debt,
whatever it is, they’re getting
compensated by the fund.
Yeah.
Not only by the client.
Now, what about if the fund
is not doing well?
Are they going to fire them?
Is the advice 100% non-biased?
It brings into the point
where a lot of times,
you create conflicts.
I’m not saying that's-- you know,
it’s not a good fund
or it’s not --
but having that conflict,
by definition,
is a problem --
- A hundred percent.
- in a family office,
-- when you are compensated
100% by the family,
and you can generate more
money as a firm, only if
they need more money.
- So, do you generally --
- Technically --
Is it generally a cut
of the profits or is it all also --?
Or is it more salary-driven
- in family offices?
- No, this is --
And this is one of the things
that’s very interesting
about multi-family office.
If you want to build
your own family office,
it's a family, you need a --
a minimum wealth of
between half a billion
and a billion dollars because --
Really?
Well, you want to
attract talents, right?
Talent is expensive.
If you run a start-up,
you need to pay a [unclear]...
because you went --
Talents, as in people like you
who are knowledgeable enough
to make the right
investments, right?
That’s the talent
you’re talking about?
Exactly. And it’s a team.
It’s not one person that
- Of course, of course, yeah.
- that can do that.
But when we put a couple
of families together,
they share the expenses.
And that’s why this model works.
But even when they share
the expenses, are those expenses
salary-driven or equity-driven
in the profits?
No, no. This is only a percentage
of the wealth that’s being managed.
So, if you’re not doing well,
obviously, your revenues
are going to go down.
Right.
But at the end of the day,
it’s only one portion.
We never had an issue
about the fees that we charge
or anything like that.
If you have an issue,
it’s going to be something
completely different because this
is not going to make
or break your investments.
Right? It’s something small.
It’s about how serious
you take the relationship,
how dedicated the team is,
and how much value
you can add to the family
because with all due respect,
these are families
with a lot of resources.
They can turn to almost
any accountant, any attorney,
any -- right?
What do you do better?
Can they be --?
Can they sleep well at night
knowing that you manage
all these issues?
That’s fascinating.
Just like an entrepreneur
or a CEO may have ambitions
to grow their start-up
from $10 million valuation
to 100 million, to a unicorn,
do family offices
or multi-family offices
have this ambition of reaching
for the most wealthy families
both because then the percentage
of the profits is the greatest
because you have more assets,
you’re putting more --
you’re investing more,
but also because of
the status of it.
Is that how it works?
I don't know if that's the status.
It’s more of the challenge
to be able to show
that what you do is really unique.
That’s what all the CEOs
are saying. Come on.
[laughs]
Look, in any business that you do,
unless you have
an incentive, right?
Yeah.
So it’s all about that.
But when you’re able to put all
of the incentives together, right?
Right.
Then it works.
But you can't have the conflicts.
The conflicts are just --
at some point, they’re just
going to destroy the relationship.
No, no. I’m sure.
That’s what it sounds like.
Are these long-term relationships,
or short-term?
How long does the average person
spend with the family?
Very long term, very long term.
We have families that have been
with us for three generations.
Three generations.
Generations.
So, that’s a very long time.
I like that you’re counting it by
generations, because essentially,
what you’re saying is that when
a new generation comes,
they have to decide --
they almost have to decide,
whether they’re continuing
to work with you
or they’re going to others, right?
It's very true.
So, the statistics says that
the second generation,
you have a 50-50 chance
for them to stay with you.
- Wow!
- The third generation...
it’s dropping
to single digits, right?
So, if you didn't --
Is that because they have
a conflict with their parents
and they want to go
on a different path
or because they know others,
or they feel like they want
to reinvent themselves?
Not necessarily.
It’s --
I’ll give you an example.
Millennials.
They have different objectives.
They have a different way
of seeing the world.
They want to do things differently.
And they see who can
accommodate that.
You know,
there’s not the common language
and it’s a problem.
And that’s why
we have younger people
also working with us
because they have
to make that decision
once the wealth is transferred,
if they’re going to stay
with that person.
You have to do
that work well in advance.
Explain to them
and help them
get to their goals, right?
They'll feel comfortable,
they’ll stay with you.
But if you don’t,
again, the statistics is terrible.
Wow!
And so, what it sounds
to me is that --
what’s really special here is that,
on one hand, you have
just as great
a responsibility as
if you’re in investment banking.
I would argue that you have
even more responsibility
because you’re dealing with
actual people and these are
relationships that you’re building.
But you have to employ
these interpersonal
relationships and skills to
actually build the trust over time.
Right?
This is not just a transactional
relationship that
will
change when you screw up.
But when you screw up
or when markets fall,
or some decisions
weren’t the optimal,
that interpersonal relationship
you have with them,
that’s where it
really counts, right?
So that you continue, and you
continue that work together.
Yes, it’s extremely personal.
I get to the point where you help
with the funeral arrangements.
- It's --
- Wow!
It's a --
It's very, very, very deep.
Of course, it’s deep
as the family wants to take it.
- Of course.
- But once they --
they are able to trust you,
then you can do a lot for them.
And you’re happy to do that.
Interesting. Okay.
So, what excites you most
about this job?
What excites you most about running
a multi-family family office?
Oh, it’s the research process.
It’s the ability to try
and build that puzzle
to understand how the world
operates because
I haven’t figured that out yet.
You’re very independent
in doing that, right?
Because you don’t have --
you can basically of --
you can offer anything.
It’s up to y --
you can bring
to the table any ideas.
Yes. The bringing the ideas
is not the problem.
It’s first of all, you have
to understand
the big picture, right?
How the world operates.
The economy, the different
cycles in the economy.
And once you understand that,
then you know which
type of investments
you want to bring into the table.
A good investment by itself
is not necessarily a good idea.
It doesn’t mean that
it’s going to go well
with the rest of the
investments that you have.
- Right.
- And --
sending the common...
the capital markets,
that’s the challenge.
That’s the big deal,
understanding that some assets
correlate over time,
but at some point,
that correlation’s going to break.
And you cannot trust that
correlation to build the portfolio.
- Right.
- And you see that
over and over again.
But unless you have a process,
and it’s all process,
process, process,
you’re going to miss that.
Then you miss out
on the most important,
critical points.
It's so, so interesting.
Alon, before we leave,
what is one thing
that I can learn
as a young entrepreneur
or a young -- you know,
let’s say, a young wealth
manager of my own?
I don’t have much wealth.
Nothing at all.
But nevertheless,
I do have to manage
whatever I do have.
What can I learn
from your experience
in managing my own wealth
as I go down the path of life
as an engineer,
as an entrepreneur or as anything?
Oh, I hope it’s not
going to sound bad.
But I learned that what you study
in school is very different
from the real world.
Right.
The economy doesn’t
operate like that.
Markets and companies
don’t operate like that.
Get your hands dirty.
Check the tires.
Do the groundwork.
Learn how the macro
environment really works.
Not necessarily what you see
in supply and demand chart.
And in scope of --
because it doesn't  really --
You need to know about hindsight.
And you know,
engineering and entrepreneurship
is all about foresight.
- So, it’s different.
- Exactly like that.
A hundred percent.
I love it. Alon, before we leave,
three words that best describe you.
Only three words?
[laughs]
- Okay.
- Three words.
The important things in life,
then I’ll say,
a husband, a father.
Yes.
A friend.
I love it.
And I love that none
of the three words are not
necessarily correlated
to the specific work
that you’re doing.
And I think that speaks
a lot about the personal nature
of the work that you’re doing,
that you’re not just an economist.
You’re not just
a financial adviser.
You’re relationship-driven
and that’s what guides it,
which I think is wonderful.
It's all about relationships.
It’s not work is work.
I love it. Alon, toda raba.
Thank you very, very much.
- And stay safe and healthy.
- Thank you very much.
I love that.
Thank you very much.
Take care.
You too.